[Music]
morning everybody welcome to sky news
live from dining street just moving out
of the way
with me who's not tomorrow that was
nigel adams a key ally and chris he's in
harris the chief whip so they were both
going in to see the prime minister when
the chief whip goes to see the prime
minister he gives him an assessment of
whether he has the party's support on
any given issue but today he will be
giving him an assessment really if he
has the party's support full stop having
lost his fifth cabinet minister in the
last 15 minutes which is a previous
loyalist brandon lewis who said it's a
matter of personal regret that this
government he says lacks honesty
integrity and mutual respect yeah now
there's a bit of confusion over the
number that have resigned it is five
because people forget about oliver died
and that was just less than a couple of
weeks ago well we've had five gone
anyway because you had rishi sunak sajid
javid michael gove simon hart and now
brandon
was that sacked um and of course five
resigned if you include oliver dowden
but five gone from his cabinet only two
of those positions having been filled
and in the junior ranks you have dozens
upon dozens of ministers who have left
their posts and while you can always
convince somebody to be the chancellor
of the exchequer does boris johnson
really have the authority to ask any of
the remaining mps you support him to go
to go into
any of those jobs i'll just show you
brandon lewis's resignation i just
wanted to ask you about the chief whip
if i may first of all i've never said
larry's out i've never seen the chief
whip in all the time i've been covering
politics go in the front door of number
10 this early in the morning that's
making a statement right there it is
going in the front could have gone in
the side and look chris heaton harris
who's the new-ish chief whip he was
appointed in february after the
partygate debacle to try and steady the
ship along with chris pincher and we
know how that will ended up
he
is said to be of the view that the prime
minister is going to find it hard to
continue he and other cabinet ministers
were in there yesterday telling the
prime minister the truth about his
position with conservative mps we know
that when michael gove told him some
hard truths yesterday morning he ended
up being sacked by the end of the day
but there have been many cabinet
ministers reportedly including his new
chancellor nadim zahawi telling the
prime minister you have not got the
support of your party and it would be
better to go now on your own terms
rather than wait to be dragged from
office but it looks at the moment if
boris johnson is going to stay on okay
so that group of them of cabinet
ministers that went in to see him
yesterday the prime minister didn't come
back in through the front door updating
people as we go because
literally minute by minute let's try and
find out what's going on uh brandon
lewis resigning was breaking news 10
minutes ago now we're seeing the chief
whip going up in the front door brandley
brennan should have been with that group
yesterday but he was stuck in northern
ireland he was in northern ireland his
flight was delayed and he came back late
last night and
he there was some confusion about
whether some people saying he had
resigned last night and that was denied
he has resigned this morning
but let's think for a minute also beyond
the drama in westminster and brandon
lewis what brandon lewis has resonated
with boris johnson he's also got
northern ireland that has had no
government for the last two months and
so he leaves northern ireland in a state
of turmoil at the moment and great
uncertainty about what is happening at
the moment regarding getting their
government up and running services up
and running and of course the northern
ireland protocol issue so a lot hanging
in the balance while boris johnson's
future is played out here talk to me
about brandon lewis um you know he's not
necessarily a household name to many of
our viewers this morning but he has been
pretty influential in this government in
all sorts of positions he has talked a
lot about how he became conservative as
a teenager he has been party chairman of
quite high profile position in the sense
of going on television and talking about
uh
doing some difficult media rounds in
that in that post and he's despite the
fact he's northern ireland secretary
which is often a position where you're
not always on the tv screens because he
is so assured boris johnson often put
him forward to come and talk to the
media on very difficult issues and he's
also been doing his bit to convince tory
mps to support the prime minister during
that leadership vote last month so he is
a loyalist he is someone who would you
would have thought would have defended
the prime minister right to the end but
if brandon lewis thinks that this is now
the end of the road for boris johnson
then that is a sign that even the really
really loyal cabinet ministers are
deserting him at the at this point now
he resigned this morning
this morning 6 47 the letter was posted
we don't know yet we will bring you as
we find out whether he warned boris
johnson but the key bits in that letter
are i cannot sacrifice my personal
integrity to defend things as we are now
and the last line a decent and
responsible government relies on honesty
integrity and mutual respect i no longer
believe those values are being upheld
and he talks about how difficult a
decision this was because of the the
difficulties in northern ireland and how
he knows the stakes of leaving his post
at the moment but clearly this is an
attempt by the cabinet to say
you cannot carry on like this we have to
have new leadership and they are not
waiting until
we expect the 1922 committee changes the
rules on monday and potentially has
another confidence vote next week
they're acting now talk to me about
helen wakeley she's also gone um not a
great uh performer when it came to media
rounds but she was she was again you
know a very solid minister wasn't she
brandon lewis is deputy chairman so they
know each other i wonder if that was a
you know interesting that that this has
happened at the same time yes she has
been she um has been
a care minister during the covert crisis
and then she's also
been a treasury minister and it's
interesting that the treasury so she
worked under rishi sunak have pretty
much deserted the ship now we saw rishi
sunak gone shortly after the very long
standing city minister john glenn left
now helen waitley is gone i mean you
barely got a functioning treasury at
this point
welch secretary we saw him stride up
downing street yesterday he was leading
the charge wasn't he indeed and
simon hart and the wealth secretary of
course he was on tv on friday morning
say when um when the full truth of the
chris pincher issue and what the prime
minister um
what was known about it was becoming
clear but the prime minister was still
trying to defend him staying on as an mp
and it was simon hart who was
in the tv studios not
defending the government line that chris
pedro should stay on as an mp but saying
look i don't think it will last a day
effectively and i i know what my own
views on this subject are so he was um
dissenting last week on this chris
pincher issue and i think the sense that
ministers are aggrieved having to go out
and say things which are untrue or
unravel within minutes was very clear um
in what's in simon hart's interviews
last friday and so he has now left his
post so and boris johnson deserted now
by five of his cabinet ministers either
resigned or sacked in the last few days
and
last night one of his private
secretaries one of his aides
he
james dudridge was out saying there's
going to be more cabinet changes
that didn't happen last night
will it happen today will boris johnson
be saying to chris eaton harris look i'm
replacing all these people and carrying
on let me just uh read what simon hart
said he said i desperately hope that i
could avoid writing this letter but alas
there seems no other option left but to
step down from my role as secretary of
state for wales he goes on to say i have
never been a massive fan of ministerial
resignations being the best means of
forcing change colleagues have done the
utmost in private and public to help you
turn the ship around but it is with
sadness that i feel we have passed the
point where this is possible i think
it's fair to say that we we're 25
probably more than 25
of those on the payroll having resigned
or one of them been sacked do we have a
functioning government
well there are at least 20 ministerial
posts vacant if you take out all the
sort of very junior bad carrier roles
which don't necessarily need to be
filled to run the government and some
ministers do more than one role so we're
20 down you you don't it's hard to see
how those people are replaced i think
simon hart's letter
saying that
i i'm not a fan of this approach to
force people from office that is what
they're now trying to do that is what
the cabinets are now trying to do to try
and force boris johnson from office by
resigning on mass and this is echoes of
you know the end of margaret thatcher
and what was come to be described as the
men as the men in grey suits going to
see her to say it time's up now
this is what the cabinet trying to do
don't wait for the 1922 committee to
force you out don't have an election
which boris johnson refused to rule out
several times yesterday and and lose
they're saying just go now for the good
of the conservative party and let
somebody else take over whether he will
heed those calls it is not clear yet
yeah that was him striding up on the
phone yesterday they often use that
trick when they're not talking to
anybody um saves them being shouted out
by the press but we give it a go anyway
and to that end i'm gonna do the papers
in just a second we've just seen the
chief whip go in yeah and uh if you're
just joining us the chief whip for the
second time in 24 hours he's gone in to
see the prime minister how unusual is
that it is unusual to see him at this
time of the morning at 6 30 in the
morning the chief whips he's the prime
minister all the time every day though
what does that chief do the chief whip
is in charge of party discipline and so
the chief whip will be saying to the
prime minister every day oh you've got
to vote on this difficult issue the this
is there are 20 people who are not sure
they want to vote for it and i'm i've
talked round two and there are others
who won't vote for it but you'll still
win or you'll only you might narrowly
lose or whatever they'll they'll give
the prime minister a sense where the
party's out on different issues and and
they'll also be in charge of
seeing whether there are any particular
issues with specific mps that they will
deal with he's gone in there with nigel
adams who's also a minister and he's one
of boris johnson's closest allies he was
um out and about doing partygate
defending the prime minister and
they will be in there talking to him
about what the options are as it stands
okay i want to try and make sense of
some of the jargon that we use for our
viewers this morning because a lot of
people who are watching you know they're
not in the westminster bubble they're
not completely sure
a lot of questions i was asked yesterday
people kept saying to me what do you
mean they've retired from uh or they've
resigned from government what does that
actually mean because are they still an
mp are they still a conservative what
does that actually mean if someone
resigns from their department so when
rishi seen that resides from the
treasury he will have had lots of
different important issues going on
pieces of legislation meetings with key
business groups he leaves the treasury
and goes home and the officials the
civil servants carry on working but
he has he leaves the building and it has
no leadership no one has taken decisions
in there he's still an mp mps can only
be kicked out by the voters they can
have the whip of the party taken away
from them but they can only be removed
as an mp by the voters but when a
minister leaves their department they
leave all of the issues that they are
presiding over in limbo and so that is
why this is a difficult decision for
ministers people were saying last night
michael gove has been crucial in trying
to get some of these issues to do with
um
dangerous cladding on buildings and
giving people compensation there are you
know hundreds of thousands of people as
we've reported who were hoping to get
compensation they are in limbo the
northern ireland government which has
been suspended for two months is in
limbo and the issues the wealth
secretary was dealing with are not being
looked at today so when
ministers have to be replaced in these
departments in order to try and get
anything done did i see a tweet um i
think uh late last night or earlier this
morning from a labour mp saying that the
the meeting that she was supposed to be
involved with the committee that she was
involved with yeah just couldn't go
ahead because there weren't any
ministers yes they put all the progress
of legislation that you never see
happens in committee rooms behind the
scenes where they go through all these
different amendments before it's put to
parliament again
this process needs mps of all parties
and
um and ministers for those departments
and you've got some departments like
michael grove's leveling up department
which has only got one minister in it so
if there's anything they need to do in
parliament today that minister will have
to do all of it but how does this impact
on our viewers at home this morning
morning wherever you're watching us from
this morning but
okay these ministers are resigning left
right and center in order to try to get
boris johnson out of the building behind
us it has to be said also that even if
he's ousted on tuesday he'll still be
prime minister until the autumn probably
yes so what does boris johnson do now
he's lost five cabinet ministers we now
have some of the super loyal people like
brandon lewis resigning sowella
braverman who we've not talked about yet
the attorney general i mean has been
incredibly loyal to boris johnson she
was recently accused of ruling the
northern his northern ireland protocol
plans to be legal just to be supportive
of the prime minister she said last
night that she thinks he should go now
and that she is thinking of running for
the leadership good first time it's
going to be a crowded field it's going
to be a crowded field um and
so we're now at that stage where people
are openly saying
his allies are openly saying the prime
minister should go and try to run
themselves so what happens well if the
prime minister
decides that it's over today or um it is
decided by people in the conservative
party that it's over next week
he what would normally happen as we saw
with david cameron and theresa may they
would announce they're going there's a
leadership contest which has uh voting
by mps then voting by conservative
members and normally the prime minister
would stay as prime minister for that
period with all the functions of being
prime minister how long's that because
you can never take you can never have no
prime minister um so that normally takes
a couple of months actually i mean with
theresa may
and andrea ledson the contest ran short
because andrea ledson pulled out so it
can be quick but with um the election of
boris johnson remember there was about
10 different candidates it all actually
took quite a long time so it can take a
couple of months while the previous
prime minister stays in office if
something different were to happen for
example boris johnson were to decide he
didn't want to stay in office then the
queen would need to appoint somebody
else to be prime minister so this is
the convention is the prime minister
stays damian hines resigned his security
minister within the last few seconds
damien hines tells us damian
well
education secretary he's now security
minister at the home office um he is i
wouldn't put him in the uber loyal to
boris johnson camp but he was seen as a
very safe pair of hands um and um after
the sad death of
james brokenshire he was given that post
as security minister and um he was
generally very well regarded in
government but this is again the um the
people who don't raise their heads above
the parapet
um we saw many of these people in that
category yesterday people like robin
walker the school's minister
and
these people are now saying we don't
want to stay in government and if you've
got someone very senior inside of
security at the home office leaving
their post
this is again can the government
function
can boris johnson appoint anyone else to
do that job so let's take a look at the
letter yes
damian hines says with regret i must
resign from the government i'm grateful
to you for asking me to return as
security minister last year it's been a
particular privilege to serve in this
role and have the opportunity to support
those working tirelessly to keep our
country safe and he talks about how he
which is the next security minister well
we're delivering into law the national
security bill the economic crime bill
and the protect duty bill so ministers
are working on all different things at
the time that they leave office he talks
about the prime minister's great
achievements with the vaccine program
and ukraine
and says but more important than any
government or leader are the standards
we uphold in public life and faith in
our democracy and public administration
because of the serious erosion in these
i've come to the conclusion the right
thing for our country and our party is
for you to stand down as prime minister
he says i'd hoped you would take this
course sooner from your own volition but
as it has become clear you intend to
stay i cannot continue to serve in your
administration so we've now got
ministers saying i'm going because
you're not going basically here's a
question if all these people start to
step down and he doesn't have enough
people to fill because they don't want
him to be prime minister but he can
still be prime minister to the autumn
then what does he do
does it mean that we've got a government
that is basically um in aspect until the
autumn
well if boris johnson were to
decide that he's going to step down
which sort of looks inevitable at some
point but um he's holding on for now
then yes he would announce there would
be um he would announce leadership
contest and then the conservative party
and the 1922 committee would work out
what the timetable is they would say
nominations first then rounds of voting
but what my question is all these people
don't want to work with uh boris johnson
boris johnson even if you during that
period so i mean what happened there
would be a question about whether they
agreed to return to their role this has
never happened before okay i've never
had before we've never had this many
residents quite excited it's very
exciting it's very unprecedented but
it's also very uncertain for a lot of
people who are relying on these
important decisions and
the
we've never had the situation before
there's a chance of course that if boris
johnson were to say look i understand
the game's up that some of them would
return to serve for a couple of months
until that contest or he may be able to
appoint other people but you'd have a
lot of new people in in crucial jobs so
i i think if the prime minister were to
do that there's a chance they would come
back but we really don't know because
this has not happened before this is
this is unprecedented so someone who was
incredibly loyal to the prime minister
until he was removed from post um so
that the position for dominic robb could
be created was um sir robert botland he
uh was the former justice secretary with
us now hello to you sir robert thanks
for joining us on the programme this
morning um thoughts on these flurry of
resignations so far this morning it's
only 20 plus seven
yes and i i think you know if the
writing wasn't on the wall last night
i'm afraid it's very clearly written on
the wall this morning and the prime
minister i think has no choice but to
leave office uh he now needs to think
about uh the good not just of the party
but actually the country and you know to
quote him back about him not wanting
politicians to talk about themselves
well now it seems to me the best way to
do that is for him to go and for us to
get back to the priorities of the people
of our country whether it's cost of
living uh the threat of war in europe
and indeed war in europe and all those
international issues that are having an
effect here at home
perhaps you can help tamara and i out
with that question that we were posing
to each other which was all these people
having resigned even if the prime
minister does go or is forced to go with
a vote of no confidence perhaps as early
as next tuesday because of the 1922
committee rule changes potentially all
these potentials um
will those people then be asked to go
back into post until we've got a new
leader given that if they don't
we don't have a functioning government
and the prime minister could still be in
number 10 until the autumn
well
a very good point kay i think i think we
are in uncharted waters i think what's
crucial is that we have enough uh people
uh carrying out the functions of
government it would be like a sort of
caretaker period where there wouldn't be
new policy initiatives but there's
plenty frankly for the government to be
getting on with uh you know i i didn't
think this prime minister had a problem
when it turned he came in terms of the
number of initiatives that he's already
announced it's it's how to deliver them
that really matters and therefore what
we need is is the minimum necessary to
do that and of course it's for the
conservative party to get on with the
job of quickly selecting a success i
think the parliamentary votes could be
held before the end of this term and
then if there needs to be a membership
ballot that could be done in august we
could have a new leader in september so
we might only be talking about a period
of a few of
six weeks or so um but but you know i
think it's important that the british
constitution is an unwritten thing it's
a thing of beauty and wonder but it's
not written down anywhere and it does
depend on all of us to be good team
players and to respect convention not to
bring the queen into any controversy uh
to to be good team players prime
minister's got an opportunity to do that
and to show at the end of his
premiership that respect for the
constitution and for our system of
government that
um just let me interrupt you
i'm so sorry we're just hearing that uh
the science minister george freeman has
also just stepped down so he has just
announced that he cannot work with the
prime minister and he has also stepped
down that's 50 mps 50 members of
government now on the government payroll
have stepped down this is not
what's he going to do
well
this is not normal as you say uh and
through their resignations
colleagues like george and others of all
friends and colleagues of mine are uh
expressing uh publicly what i and others
have been saying now for the last 24
hours or so it's increasingly obvious
that i'm afraid because of because of
personality issues because of the lack
of trust that now exists that the prime
minister cannot go on i'm desperately
sad about it okay we came into office on
a one nation ticket you know i believe
in one nation conservatism uh to my
bones and i wanted this prime minister
to bring the country together we dealt
with covid we we we had an unprecedented
challenge these were huge and serious
challenges and he's capable he's been
capable of so much but no longer we need
fresh leadership and we need a a a
better leadership in order to deal with
the huge challenges that our country
faces
yeah um he's not going anywhere though
is he and he is the prime minister you
know we have to recognize
the office of prime minister we have to
give it due respect but he has said that
uh in order to get rid of me you'll have
to bathe your hands in blood i think
that's a shakespearean reference he's
just not gonna go unless he's forced to
well okay you've put it very well if i
may say so respect for the office of
prime minister but you know that
includes the incumbent the incumbent has
to respect the office that they hold and
i can't think of any greater respect for
that office than by honoring
constitutional norms by accepting the
verdict of the party that he now needs
to go not not just for the good of the
party but for the good of our country uh
we we are better than this he is better
than this i think at the end of it i
hope he's asking himself this morning
really can i now go on with so few uh
colleagues supporting me and i think
he'll find the answers are resounding no
and then actually we can deliver the
agenda that i know he believes hidden
which is one nation conservative
government bringing our country together
rising to the challenge of the cost of
living and international threats and uh
being serious
about the next few years and getting the
job done to again use his famous quote
um
you have been a loyal lieutenant to this
prime minister for a very long time i've
spoken to you often and you've been on
those media rounds as we describe them
where the minister goes out to talk to
the public via the television studios in
the mornings um what was the tipping
point for you what made you think i
i can't support him any longer
well not dissimilar to many other
colleagues i i was absolutely prepared
to give our elected prime minister and
our elected leader the the benefit of
the doubt when it came to
some of the issues relating sadly to
parties
and to other issues where sadly the
truth seems to have been different from
the original version of events but you
know there's a cumulative effect of this
and i've always felt okay that at some
point there would be a last straw moment
and i think i'm afraid in the
obfuscation and excuse making that we've
seen in the last few days surrounding
his former deputy chief whip it became
increasingly clear to me
that colleagues were being sent out to
say things that just weren't true
you cannot run a government on that
basis the british people expect
straightforwardness integrity and
honesty from our leaders sometimes
things go wrong and when things go wrong
you need to be able to explain that a
man up and explain it
and i i saw an absence of that this week
and it's with huge sadness that i've
concluded that this prime minister can
no longer go on
well we're just hearing from number 10
they're saying that he's going to carry
on with his reshuffle this morning that
needs to go ahead of course because of
the changes that we've seen over the
last couple of days um just reading from
george freeman's letter if you'll
indulge me please sir robert i wondered
if you could comment on this i'm afraid
the culmination of your lack of
transparency and candor with parliament
and willingness to ask your ministers to
mislead parliament your removal of key
pillars of the ministerial code
your handling of your appointment of a
deputy chief whip who it turns out you
knew how the history of sexual abuse
allegations is just too much this is
seriously damaging public trust and
respect for government democracy and the
law and this great party's long
tradition at the party of standards
character conduct integrity and duty to
office and country before partisan
self-interest
and still he goes on with a reshuffle
very strong words from george freeman i
i don't disagree with any of them the
conservative party is about respect for
our constitution our rule of law
margaret thatcher talked about freedom
under the law uh it's something that i
believe
in to my heart and i think every
conservative does believes the same and
therefore when you have uh somebody who
seems to think that their idea of the
premiership is them in it i'm afraid
that's not good enough uh we as
conservatives are as people who are
stewards of our of our country and our
government uh should expect and demand
more from our leaders and that's why
there's one word i'm afraid that uh he
needs to listen to which is
go i was flabbergasted yesterday when i
was watching the telly at home and i
heard that the senior cabinet had gone
in to see him and the chief whip was
there figuratively with the whiskey and
the revolver and still he said no i'm
going nowhere did you think the game was
up last night
well i thought the game was up much
earlier in the day and
frankly
the one person in whose hands uh this
could have been dealt with is is the
prime minister this could have been so
different
if there was a a proper application to
the issues at hand a real focus
on uh some of the
question marks and challenges about the
way he does things the way he runs
government it was up to him
to make those changes to accept that we
can all do better you know
self-improvement is something i again
very much believe we can always do
better we can always improve and i i
think that lack of
self-awareness almost and on the sort of
uh doggy belief that uh you know it
doesn't matter how you get there we will
we'll muddle through i'm afraid just
isn't good enough the joke's over now
and it's time to leave office
nadeem zahawi uh the new chance that i
spoke to him yesterday on the programme
and he insisted that the prime minister
had integrity do you think he does
well i'm afraid he's displaying uh that
that that he no longer has that and you
know it's with huge sadness that i say
that because i i think that there are so
many qualities about royce johnson i've
known him for many years and i've
admired a lot of what he has done you
know through covid through brexit we got
things done and we got a lot done uh
under his leadership and there are many
many good things he'll be able to point
to but you know the manner of uh one's
leaving is also very important and it's
how somebody will be judged and if if a
leader leaves with good grace observing
constitutional norms and accepting that
however
high uh he or she might have come they
only serve
at the pleasure of the british people
and indeed their party then i think he
will be able to emerge with at least
some of his reputation intact at the
moment he's single-handedly shredding
that uh through every utterance we hear
from number 10 this morning this is now
an unreal situation to talk about
reshuffling the day who's who's going to
who's going to accept office uh it is
just she's just absurd and we need to
end this
end this fast now
i want you've read my mind i i wanted to
ask you sir robert how he will because
we are entering the end game however you
look at it the prime minister um is done
uh how do you think he will be
remembered will he be the prime minister
who just wouldn't
leave office until he was dragged out
kicking and screaming or will he be the
prime minister who got brexit done
well look
again it's in his hands i think that he
wants to be remembered as the prime
minister who got brexit done and who
stewarded us through the most
unprecedented peacetime challenge in our
history the covid crisis uh three
tumultuous years it's not about length
of time sir it's about what you did in
office and he'll be able to point to a
lot of achievements i was honored to
serve as his lord chancellor getting
important criminal justice reforms done
and we've we've achieved huge change to
sentencing uh in our country which i
believe will make us safer lots of
things he'll be able to point to with
pride
but now is the time to uh
exit the stage and to accept that with
great sadness his premiership is over
it's good to talk to you sir robert
thank you so much for taking the time
thank you thank you
so just in that a few minutes 10 minutes
that i've been speaking to robert
another two resignations tomorrow well
first of all the prime minister
according to a number 10 sword is
continuing with his reshuffle so that is
apparently what he's doing in there with
the chief whip chris eden harris try and
decide who's going to fiddle these posts
and um
well even if he is able to fill some of
them
they are leaving quicker than he can
fill them and george freeman i'm just
reading through his letter doesn't
actually say he's resigning he's
actually just telling the prime minister
to resign and he says that um he blames
the chaos in number 10 and now he just
says the um i'm actually it's actually
slightly surprised in a way that george
freeman didn't resign yesterday he's not
known
as someone who's being who's a massive
supporter of the prime minister but he's
now saying the chaos in number 10 the
breakdown of cabinet collective
responsibility abandonment of the
ministerial code
the defense of impropriety insults to
conservatism i believe in and stand for
so he's just saying the prime minister
should go and um and that's what and
that's what should happen somebody will
give a ring and see that it reads like a
resignation
but we had a few others yesterday as
well one saying the private if the prime
minister doesn't go i will resign so
you've now just got mps as well as
ministers resigning mp's just openly
saying to the prime minister you should
go now there are some suggestions when i
was talking to some senior conservatives
yesterday and saying look we had this
leadership vote how would it go no one's
in any doubt really that the prime
minister does not have very much support
in the conservative party yeah um so
we've lost four people this morning we
have lost
brandon lewis the biggest name he's from
the cabinet we've lost
uh helen waitley the treasury minister
um and we've lost
damian hines the security minister
george freeman is calling on the prime
minister to go
okay um what's going to happen today
well yesterday
i had a day well who knows we we may
we're likely to see more resignations we
may well see more cabinet resignations
because simon hart's letter that's the
welsh secretary who resigned late last
night he said i don't want to do this to
force you from office but that's what
i'm having to do so we may get more
resignations from the cabinet in an
effort to get the prime minister to go
we may get the prime minister as
suggested by number 10 source appointing
new people to some of these cabinet jobs
sacking people and appointing new people
as he sacked michael gove last night in
probably the most shocking twist and
turn of this whole saga
i've just had a question from a viewer
saying does the prime minister actually
read these letters of resignation or
does somebody read them for him
well i suspect he's aware of their
content and
i think most conservatives think the
prime minister is aware of the
predicament that he's in and even he's
not aware of it people like chris heat
and harris the chief whip will tell him
the predicament that he's in but i think
as we often seen with the prime minister
not sacking people when they commit
misdemeanors you remember he didn't sack
matt hancock uh for breaking the covered
rules matt hancock resigned and he
didn't want to sacrifice pincher until
he resigned himself and then he was
forced to sit to withdraw the whip he
doesn't like to be bounced into things
and he seems to want to do this on his
own terms but the message very clearly
from conservative mps is stopped
dragging us all down it is a resignation
letter i'm just being told that george
freeman is your resignation letter okay
well that's five then four then this
morning yeah i'm sure there'll be more
to come i mean probably the biggest
beast would have would be the northern
ireland secretary brandon absolutely
fiercely loyal to the prime minister
fiercely lost the prime minister all the
way through partygate all the way
through all of the difficulties he's had
he was also dealing with a particularly
important issue of this northern ireland
brexit arrangements of course you
remember that he in order to try and
make this work in the way the prime
minister intended he suggested that
international law may be broken in a
specific and limited way he was bringing
this controversial legislation through
parliament he's obviously got a very
sensitive job at a time with no
government in northern ireland and he's
he is now going and saying to the prime
minister integrity matters you have lost
that it's time to go and just to clarify
before we recap for people who were just
uh tuning our way this morning what does
that then mean for um the changes to the
northern ireland protocol does that mean
that is now on hold until he fills that
north well the legislation has been
introduced to parliament yeah and it's
happening here or need to be taken
through um so it was i think it's had a
vote already it's a second reading vote
so it will need to now there are further
stages down the line but when a
government minister
when a secretary of state leaves their
post they leave someone else to pick all
this stuff up and if the gut the whole
government would afford we should get a
new prime minister then they would need
to decide what they want to do so
everything is in limbo
oh okay tomorrow thanks very much indeed
uh you're very welcome to join us on the
breakfast show here on sky news this
morning we're trying to unpick it for
you as best we can it's a very very
fluid situation i think i'm right in
saying uh coming up i'm going to be
speaking uh to the former director of
comms at downing street he was on
yesterday
more than a third of a million people
had a look on our twitter feed to see
what he had to say that's aleister
campbell back again this morning
boris johnson continues to fight off
calls for his dismissal speaking again
to chris bryant he was here yesterday he
questioned the prime minister yesterday
as part of that liaison committee what
was the mood like as it started to
trickle through the news that more and
more people were resigning and that
there was a posse of cabinet ministers
waiting for him at downing street when
he came back
and somebody else who was there was the
conservative mp tobias elwood as the
prime minister tries to cling on to
power the backbencher and also chairman
of the defense committee what does he
make of it all
this morning a flurry of resignations in
the last half an hour taking the total
number now to i think 50 tomorrow 50 50.
yeah there you go uh leaving boris
johnson's government george freeman the
science minister is the latest to step
to step down forgive me uh hot on the
heels of the security minister damian
hines
the treasury minister helen wakeley and
most significantly perhaps the northern
ireland secretary brandon lewis let's
take a look again at how things stand
this morning
since the resignation of the chancellor
and the health secretary on tuesday
evening there's been a deluge of
conservative mps handing in letters of
resignation the total is now at 50.
here's how things are looking this
morning four members of the cabinet but
if you take into account oliver dowden
who resigned a couple of weeks ago that
would be five
19 ministers 22 parliamentary private
secretaries four envoys and one vice
chairman have resigned from their
positions let's take a look again at
what brandon lewis the fourth cabinet
minister to go wrote in his letter to
the pm
this was on twitter and this is what the
northern ireland secretary had to say
a decent and responsible government
relies on honesty integrity and mutual
respect it's a matter of profound
personal regret that i must leave
government as i no longer believe those
values are being upheld
alastair campbell is with us now hello
to you uh mr campbell you were very
forthright in your views yesterday and
still the prime minister is in power
well he's in the building behind you i
don't think we can call it in power we
don't have a functioning government we
don't have a functional prime minister
and this is what happens when you put
somebody like him in charge boris
johnson is somebody who thinks the rules
don't apply to him
he's operated by that his entire
existence and what you're seeing here
is a single human being testing massive
constitutional principles he talks about
this mandate that he got from the
british people
he got the votes from the people of
uxbridge he was the leader of the
conservative party who won
the election he therefore became and
remainders as prime minister you can
only govern with continuing consent of
the people you can only govern with the
support of parliament which is losing
and you can only govern with the support
of your cabinet which he's losing as
well and so he is now seeking yet again
to say that the normal rules of life and
the politics do not apply to him and
he's damaging the country in a way that
i worry is irreparable you've seen there
with brandon lewis brandon lewis is gone
i've been you know agitating against
brandon knows for some time over the
northern ireland protocol i think he
should have gone some time ago because
breaking international law on such a
vital matter of public interest is
frankly grossly irresponsible but how
can you now have a functional government
when that one of the biggest challenges
this government faces who's he going to
put into northern ireland now who can he
actually ask to take this on so i just
think that the whole thing is what
happens when you get one narcissist i
think probably sociopathic because this
is now utter bunker mentality without
any sense of responsibility to the wider
world and these cabinet ministers fair
play some of them have stepped up
they've all got to step up and they've
all got to say i'm sorry your time's up
out you go off you go and we'll have to
try and sort this mess out after you've
gone
they tried that yesterday it didn't seem
to work
well they tried it kay but you know th
they're doing it in their own different
ways michael govind seems went and said
to him listen
your time's up and what was johnson's
response it was to you know
dig down deeper into the bunker take out
the revolver and shoot michael gove
there will be others in there i don't
know if it's true that pretty patel has
told him that he has to go i don't know
i only realize you do or what people are
telling you there's larry the cat on you
on the doorstep larry the cat right now
would be a better prime minister than
boris johnson anybody on the planet
would be a better prime minister than
borrowers johnson why because he's not
capable of governing this is what he
lives for getting into massive scrapes
and then trying to get out of them
um tomorrow just reminds me of an
article that
boris johnson wrote when gordon bryan
was holed up in number 10 seemingly
clinging on for dear life it is you know
perhaps something that desperate prime
ministers do
well i do think that was a very
different situation gordon brown
fought the election against david
cameron the outcome was unclear yes
david cameron got the biggest number of
seats but he didn't get a majority and
gordon i think behaved incredible
responsibility responsibly and i
actually was in the room with gordon
brown when he was on the phone to nick
clegg and i can remember word for word
the words gordon said to nick clay nick
we cannot keep the queen hanging around
for ages you have to make your mind up
and nick lake made his mind up to go
with david cameron so i think that is
completely different gordon brown was
actually trying to make sure that the
constitutional principles were upheld
what's happening with this guy is he's
sitting there thinking okay i've got
away with lying to the queen about
prorogation of parliament i wonder if i
can get away with doing it again now the
idea of this guy now leading the
conservative party in the general
election is frankly ridiculous he's
becoming utterly ridiculous i think
loathing of him is turning to absolute
disgust but the only thing i care about
in this case is the damage that's been
doing to the country i always get i
talked to you yesterday i was getting
hundreds hundreds of bids from news news
organizations around the world this
story is playing out right around the
world we are a global joke and until
this guy goes the world will continue to
laugh at us and that will continue to
damage us
we are you know we rather call ourselves
the mother of all parliaments and are a
little bit superior when it comes to
other parliaments around the world how
come
somebody who it would appear that almost
all of the politicians that he
represents want him out can still stay
in power what does that say about our
political system
it says that our political system
depends entirely on the honourability
of the people we elect to positions of
high office and this is what happens
when you elect somebody utterly
dishonorable when margaret thatcher was
confronted by political reality of her
cabinet colleague saying to her sorry
margaret you've been a marvelous prime
minister for us you've been a great
leader for us but time's up she went
when theresa may was confronted by the
reality of what happened to her she went
people were tony blair when tony blair
after 10 years in office but took a
decision eventually that it was time to
move on gordon brown was taking over he
went there are certain pressures in
politics and sometimes you have to lead
on them other times you have to respond
on them and i do think out of this there
has got to be a fundamental review both
of our political system and indeed of
our media culture because i think the
media and particularly the right wing
press has a massive responsibility for
getting this guy into office in the
first place for brexit which is going to
be his only legacy and that is the
tragedy of this whole thing a liar and a
crook was put into downing street to
quotes and gets brexit done we're going
to get rid of johnson but brexit we're
going to have to live with for some time
so that this is what's happened okay we
put a liar and a crook into a position
where in our constitution it depends on
people who get elected to parliament
being honorable he's utterly
dishonorable he's a disgrace to politics
he's a disgrace to parliament and to
this country and the sooner he's out of
that building preferably in the back of
a black mariah the better
well that's not going to happen as we
both know but it's a good sign by um
is it him though or is it the people
that are around him you know are the
people around him strong enough to you
know there's no hezer in there at the
moment so there's nobody of his stature
there's no elder statesman to go in and
say
time's up off you go
well that is a problem but that's what
happens when this goes back to who and
what he is as a leader he has
deliberately surrounded himself with
weak people he's appointed the p there
are people in that cabinet who wouldn't
get a job you know as driving a van i
mean they're just not very good people
they're not very good at what they do
can you imagine nadine doris in any
other cabinet in history can you imagine
suela bravaman is now talking about
putting herself forward for the
leadership i mean these are fourth-rate
people so there may be people in there
and it's and it's not the job people are
saying why can't the civil servants get
him out it's not their job they have to
try to make things work as best they can
i also i did an interview on irish radio
yesterday and stanley johnson johnson's
father was on still defending him still
saying he's honest still saying he's
honorable still saying he's the right
person for the job i mean for heaven's
sake are his family not going to step up
is his brother not his brother's not
going to step up is his sister not going
to step up this guy is doing massive
damage to one of the most important
countries in the world anybody who has
access to him should be getting the
message in for heaven's sake just you
know do the decent thing do the
honorable thing resign and let the
country try to rebuild from the absolute
chaos that you've created good to talk
to you as always alistair thanks very
much indeed for joining us thank you um
bye-bye the prime minister was at the
liaison committee yesterday which is
basically the chair people of all of the
other committees in parliament and he
was answering questions from them this
is one of the things that happened
you're asking about something that is
not going to happen
unless everybody's saying crazy is to
try and uh you know uh
you know have a new uh
can i just
remind you that when the prime minister
major
seemed to be threatening a general
election because he was having trouble
with the maastrict bill
it did his no reputation any good at all
in that meeting he's with us now
um i saw quite a few obviously it was
being a screen live on sky at the time
and i saw a few of you checking your
phones from time to time what what were
you aware of was happening in downing
street chris while you were in that
committee meeting
well we knew that you know more people
were resigning we knew that more
uh the cabinet ministers were apparently
going to downing street to tell him that
it was time to go
i don't know whether you've ever seen
the musical hamilton i've always thought
that the best
musical song that represents what
politics is all about is that song the
room where it happens the room where it
happens because that's kind of where you
want to be as a politician in the room
where it happens and it was really weird
yesterday because we had the prime
minister in front of us but i couldn't
really tell whether this was the room
where it was happening or not and
because so many things seem to be going
on elsewhere and we knew more of what
was happening than he did it was like i
think it's called dramatic irony isn't
it when when the audience knows more
than the characters that they're
watching and i i mean i have to say i
think we're in a very very dangerous
position now
the um
the the british constitution
relies on two things first of all all on
parliamentary democracy not a
presidential system
so the prime minister doesn't have a
mandate at all and the prac the only
mandate um is for the for the governing
party that wins the general election and
has a majority of the seats in the house
of commons and and if the trust of that
party
has gone from their leader then that
person no longer has a mandate to run
the country
but i think he's genuinely
um
i'm not a medical man but i think he's
unhinged
i think you think he's completely
delusional now and that is terribly
dangerous in our system because the
second fundamental principle is honor
we rely in because we don't have a
written constitution and there's nothing
that says um you know if the prime
minister
um goes beyond the pale or or does
something that is completely out of
order who steps in that there's nothing
to say that in the british constitution
so it relies on the prime minister being
honorable and being able to read the
writing on the wall
but at the moment the writing on the
wall is like 18 foot high and in
you know burning capital letters and he
still can't read it um but we have we
haven't got a security minister anymore
um half the departments have no
ministers in them at all
uh me meetings in parliament have been
which are meant to be considering
legislation today have been cancelled
because there's no ministers to stand up
and so we don't have a government we're
not functioning and that puts the
country
in a very dangerous position
and i can't see i i mean it was
interesting yesterday when i pushed the
prime minister on if there were another
vote of confidence um in him in the
conservative party and he lost it would
he go
i don't think he said yes
i don't think that's dangerous
don't think it would be up to him by
then well who is it up to then you see
that's the whole point in our system it
relies on having an honorable person as
prime minister
who knows when that when the game is up
but if you if you've had
a third of the cabinet have resigned and
more of the cabinet have done this
rather odd thing of going and saying i'm
sorry prime minister it's time that you
went the game's up this cannot continue
and but still haven't resigned maybe for
some kind of vague honorable reason or
because they think they're indispensable
to the nation or something i don't know
what um but
in that
and sue braverman the the oddest of lot
saying um i think he should go
um and i'm going to stand for um leader
and talking of delusional um but um
still not resigning i mean it's like
honor has evaporated and i suspect
that's because in the end
i i don't know when you watch him
when i was watching him yesterday his
eyes weren't really focusing on us and
he he left one minute he would be very
very
um
you know booster-ish billy bunter you
know sort of ah isn't it golly gosh it's
absolutely amazing this i have never had
so much fun in my life and then the next
moment sad terribly terribly sad and i
just think there's there's a bit of an
abandoned child in there bear with me
one second because i'm just hearing that
the pensions minister guy oppelmann has
now resigned i made that five so far
this morning carry on chris bryant sorry
uh right well i mean it makes the point
again doesn't it you know there are so
many parts of government that just
simply cannot function today
he won't be able to replace all of these
people and we can't just let this drift
for another weekend
we have enemies around the world russia
china others i mean the security
services yesterday were making very
serious um uh claims about what uh what
chinese operatives are trying to do in
the uk at the moment
we need to be on top of these things we
can't have a government that simply
isn't functioning
and um
the prime minister in response to that i
suppose chris brown he would say
you can be as rude as you want about me
chris brian i'm the prime minister and
we know from downing street sources that
he's going ahead with his reshuffle this
morning
well i i think he he will find it very
difficult to complete that reshuffle he
won't have a full set of ministers and i
would just say to
um you know somebody like pretty patel
um
who for all the rows that i've had with
her in many different places
um
i think pretty you you believe that
um the security of this country matters
i think you have a duty now you have a
duty
and you know what you have to do
but she's already told him to go hasn't
she are you suggesting that it would
take uh pretty patel to resign as home
secretary to uh force the prime minister
to do the same thing
well i note that none of th well the
chancellor's gone but um
uh that i think the home secretary has a
special duty for the security of the
nation and i worry
and just as julian smith said earlier on
i i think um radio 4
um that this is a trump moment i don't
mean that boris johnson is going to try
and get people to you know rush the
capital kind of thing or rush parliament
square because because i don't think the
people are with the prime minister here
but but he
it's a bit like alice through the
looking glass isn't it i mean nothing is
what it seems
he he talks about his mandate but he
doesn't have a mandate there is no
personal mandate that is narcissism it's
a form of sociopathy
on that note we'll leave it there thank
you for joining us on the program thank
you chris bryant who is at the liaison
committee yesterday um tomorrow as we
were chatting to chris ryan um another
resignation yes guy opperman the
pensions minister and in his letter he
says to the prime minister you know i
was particularly angry about the
breaches of the covered rules in january
of last year
and
that is because he tragically lost
his twins i believe they were premature
and couldn't visit his wife in hospital
because of the covered rules so he was
very angry about the partygate scandal
he said he'd hoped the prime minister um
he believed the prime minister when he
told him he was resetting drawing a line
under it having a new team and that
doesn't seem to have happened so that is
a very pointed resignation letter from
guy operand and a reminder of how we got
here this is not just about chris
pincher and the current difficulties
it's a lot of residual anger because of
partygate and because for many mps the
breach of trust over owen patterson so
this is a number of issues and clearly
he's come to the conclusion that he
cannot support the prime minister
anymore okay tamara thanks so much